stress dream some stress streams likely
happening for joe burrow as he tries to
get himself ready to play this season
his surgeon says he's on track for fool
go for the start of the 2021 season now
there's different ways you can look at
that and i'll talk about that in a
second but the idea that he'd be a
hundred percent come week one
is significant when you consider the
severity of the injury yeah when it
happened in the season more than just a
torn acl badly torn acl other damage to
the knee to be ready to go at the start
of the season is great but if you say
he's on track for full go for the start
of the season that could imply
that he won't be full go until the start
of the season which could impair his
ability to prepare training camp in
preseason yeah no i mean i i would think
yes things are all i mean as we hear or
read or anything things are going in the
right direction it's just about you know
how far along down the road do they get
as far as training camps concerned you
know where's he at when it starts oh
okay he's at 80 percent all right where
we're going to have to you know come up
with a detailed plan as far as how we
want to practice some how much wear and
tear do we want on that leg you know so
we can let it get stronger get closer to
100 so i would think those things are
going to be evaluated kind of you know
on the fly yeah he's on track for a full
go for the start of the season yeah full
go okay full go too i mean that you know
implies a lot there as well right i mean
like you talked about it's not a hundred
percent that doesn't mean he's gonna be
the same joe burrow we saw before the
injury and that's
that's one of my concerns and to me
that's one of the things that
i think will kind of be paramount to the
bengal's success to a degree mike i mean
we how many weeks did we talk about it
last year how slippery this damn guy is
how great he is at getting out of
trouble right to me that's going to be
the big thing is how far along is he in
that process to be able to make those
plays that we you know ood and awed
about last year
yeah and uh that that really is a
question for a team that that
is trying its damnedest to become
competitive in one of the best divisions
in all of football
and at what point do you protect the guy
from himself and i say that because you
didn't get a lot of sense last year as
joe burrow was playing with reckless
abandon each and every week that the
bengals were all that concerned about
protecting him from himself within the
confines of a game yeah now you got to
protect him from himself as he pushes to
get back and get ready to go against the
vikings the bears and the steelers not
three cupcake defenses right out of the
gates definitely not and i i would i
would hope that
because of like the circumstances you're
talking about and everything like that
that there's a little bit of a different
approach from the cincinnati bangles
because of that early on in the year you
know first off
i don't know mike i think you and i were
both shocked with how much they put on
this plate to start it last year right i
mean we were shocked it was it was joe
burrow shotgun let's throw it 45 times a
game and you're right they had you know
not a plan to protect him i mean he was
getting killed the first six seven weeks
of the year i mean one car crash hit
after another so
i i would hope that they're not going to
play that style of football to begin
with either i don't know if that's
sustainable to just say we're going to
drop back and throw it 45 48 55 times a
game you know what we got these old
lyman you got joe mixon and you got a
quarterback who it can be a superstar so
don't put it all on him to be in the
shotgun and make all those plays and
everything happen especially early in
the year when he's trying to get back
and get back
healthy yeah hey look it's going to be a
challenge for the bengals and
zach taylor the third year coach of the
cincinnati bengals there were rumors
making the rounds late last season that
the bengals may make a coaching change
and it got to the point where the
bengals had to issue a statement right
the day after the season ended that
they're not firing zach taylor that is
an unusual move but it just shows you
that they understand there was something
to it not simply because we mentioned it
or wrote about it i mean the rumors were
out there there was an expectation
people that i know and trust that it was
actually going to happen i don't know
how close it came right but that has
more urgency for zach taylor this year
he's going to want to get off to a good
start he's going to want to change the
narrative the team has not been good the
last two seasons they were so bad his
first season that they got themselves in
position to get joe burrow but they're
gonna have to make some strides quickly
and when you have two games against the
browns two games against the ravens two
games against the steelers
that is not the way
to an easy record that gets you close to
500 or on the right side of it and the
good news is no 500 records anymore
barring ties eight eight and one is the
only way that that's the tough thing
about them right mike i mean they could
be better and improved but in that
division
i know exactly right you're exactly
right right and then you know mike
another thing i'll ask you just a little
bit about burrow like how much do you
think that conversation
uh with zach taylor the bengals coaches
had to do with the fact that the
quarterback did get hurt
at the end of the year do you think that
like management kind of looked at them
like hey what the hell why did you get
the guy hurt why'd you kill him every
week i mean
you know how would you feel if you were
the owner of the bengals with this whole
situation
well you get yourself quickly into a
circular logic where okay hey the team
sucked this year well yeah we stunk
because the quarterback was hurt we
would have been better if he wasn't yeah
but you got him hurt by not protecting
him better but wait a minute you're not
providing me with the players i need to
protect him better i think at the end of
the day here's the reality mike brown
owner of the team does not like to pay
his coaches to not work and if you have
time left on your contract that the
bengals would have to buy out
that is the best protection possible
against you getting fired before that
period in your contract ends that's how
it works so uh
and that's why i think it was so
significant the rumors were out there
that the bengals were even considering
it because they don't like to fire guys
before their contract gets to the point
where they owe them nothing more so
we'll see i think a lot of pressure on
zach taylor this year and that pressure
could influence
the extent to which maybe they rush joe
burrow onto the field before they should
the reality is he's going to want to go
he wants to compete he's fearless he's
fearless to a fault he is he's to the
point where it hurts him and the team
because he he's not bashful about
putting himself in those
those compromising situations and i
could see him pushing to get out there
week one even if he's not
as ready as he could be yeah no i think
he is that kind of guy i agree with you
mike i mean he's a he's a psycho in a
good way you know i i say that with with
you know
uh with redeeming qualities that i like
about him yeah he puts his body on the
line you could tell he loves the sport
he's consumed by it and he lives on the
edge on a play-by-play basis with a lot
of the magic he pulls and slipping and
sliding through the pocket and making
plays down the field and all that he was
awesome to watch last year and he has a
charisma about him
and a way about him
that can change an organization that's
been in the dumps for a long time and
that's why it hurt to see him get hurt
because you felt like things were kind
of changing around just the belief in
that building everything like that and
that's where it's going to be
interesting this year to just kind of
see where it resets where it all goes
from here here going forward
yeah and uh borough a key part of the
future of that team and as we see
quarterbacks in other cities become
dissatisfied with their situations you
better make the guy happy you don't want
him to wake up one day and say
i think i'd be better off for the
balance of my career with a different
organization so the bengals need to get
help around him and they need to inspire
some confidence in borough that he's not
wasting his career with a team that has
perpetually been in that in that muck
ever since they had the five straight
playoff appearances none of which
resulted in the playoff victory which
just adds to this perception that this
team can't get out of yeah neutral and
it's going to be even harder in that
division with the the three great teams
that they have to compete with now we're
going to do a comeback player of the
year draft coming up in hour number two
there's a chance joe burrow will make an
appearance on that list when we do that
later in the program
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports